super teams have been destroyed order  has officially been restored  unpredictable moments create a  monumental impacts high-powered duos  linked up a shot at redemption and a  chance for a young generation to rise  but enough with all this you know what  time it is man 82 games running back  it's wide open  just watch got the hearse they strapped  up the church say my name okay to ask  for the worst me and a cypher preach  better back on the first hit one a besom  you gotta go beserk final destination  echinacea stop my state of sleep  deprivation hey honest starts knew  you're worth new studies they bring it  back reimbursing through it oh we are  fire rung up  why a higher traveler pack doctor